[Music]  [Music]  so don't you bring me down  today  technique is only a quarter of it  passion and drive is like 100  of it when you start you just have to  push that breath out  it's an aggression it comes from the  what  not not well i give a [ __ ] what it  sounds like to be like  i know you all want to be so perfect the  recording of beautiful that  take you here the one take vocal i  didn't like it because i wanted to do  take after tag  but this has to be perfect but this note  has to be great the writer of the song  taught me to appreciate the beauty and  imperfections  and that is truth certainly  it's hard to debris and just like the  little breath and the little quiver  it's so meaningful every student can  learn from this course how to better  trust yourself  what to look out for what to listen to  when to project when to be silent  so that you can take in everything and  use it to your advantage  [Music]  i'm christina aguilera and this is my  master class  you